les six départements du centre val de
loire exposent leurs atouts et savoir
faire au sein de la plus grande ferme de
france
françois bonneau le président du conseil
régional a pu en profiter depuis ce
matin ils rencontrent les acteurs qui
participent à la renommée de notre
région en direct de la porte de
versailles à paris arthur nice
vous avez retrouvé françois bonneau
exactement lucie bonjour à vous bonjour
monsieur bono alors ce matin vous êtes
arrivés bien avant l'ouverture du salon
vers 8 heures vous avez rencontré des
éleveurs de quoi avez vous parlé avec
eux des éleveurs qui sont un des visages
de l'agriculture de notre région régions
céréalières mais région de la grande
diversité du maraîchage de l'élevage et
ce matin j'ai eu le plaisir de voir en
effet des éleveurs notamment des
éleveurs ovins des éleveurs ovins et
c'était très intéressant d'être dans ce
dialogue
les élevages connaît une période est une
période difficile difficile parce que
les cours sont souvent problématique
difficile parce qu'il faut s'adapter à
une nouvelle donne qui est celle des
circuits courts
difficile aussi parce que les évolutions
climatiques rendent les conditions
d'élevage est ce que vous leur proposez
on a avec eux abordé les interventions
structurelles de la région ça veut dire
quoi
et bien quand on ne peut
garder dans ses granges dans ces hangars
que le fourrage qui est nécessaire à une
en hiver si jamais l'année d'après
saison est très sèche et qu'on récolte
moins de fourrage alors on n'aura pas
assez de fourrage pour toute l'année et
donc on a discuté d'un plan que je mets
en place qui permettra d'agrandir le
stockage on a parlé d'un dispositif
intéressant et hermes et fourragères et
fourrages c'est quoi eh bien c'est la
possibilité pour des éleveurs de bovins
d'ovins d'avoir des barrières mobiles
des barrières mobiles ça permet de ne
pas ouvrir un champ de 5 hectares où dix
hectares de l'ouvrir progressivement
c'est beaucoup de travail pour les
éleveurs mais il y à une aide de la
région qui est mise en place et j'ai
respecté savoir s'il fallait que nous
allions plus loin dans ses interventions
dans ces aides
alors on a rencontré un éleveur
qui aurait souhaité aborder avec vous un
sujet qui n'a pas eu le temps de le
faire je vous propose de l'écouter pour
compenser le manque de fourrage et la
perte des tas d animaux parce qu'en fait
elles ont manqué d herbe donc l ont pas
fait d'ailleurs croissance qu'elle
aurait dû faire pendant la belle période
on a dû compenser par de parts de
l'aliment du commerce et donc ça c'est
un coup est donc derrière voilà ce qui
aurait été bien c'est un petit peu plus
aidés et peut-être un peu plus tôt pour
pour justement acheter pouvoir acheter
ce qu'il faut pour nourrir les animaux
quoi les trésoreries sont
en agriculture sont quand même
très faible depuis depuis quelques
années déjà et donc des des problèmes
comme ça ça accentue encore le phénomène
et c'est ça met encore plus en
difficulté les les accusations
voilà on l'a entendu vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure juste avant les
conditions cet été on était vraiment
catastrophique une sécheresse très
importante très longue
cet éleveur nous disait qu' il était
contraint à acheter de la nourriture
pour pouvoir nourrir ses bêtes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la région leur
apportent également une aide financière
il ya deux types d'interventions pour
que sur les années qui viennent
les agriculteurs leurs exploitations
soient plus résistantes avec un meilleur
stockage avec moins de consommation de
surfaces qui sont abîmés par les animaux
au moment du pâturage ça nous mettons en
place
et s'agissant des aides ponctuelles qui
correspondent à ce que décrit
d'agriculteurs c'est à dire une
situation de trésorerie qui est très
tendu parce qu'il faut acheter des
produits pour que la région puisse
intervenir il faut d'abord qu'il y ait
une classification des territoires au
niveau national comme territoire
relevant des aides particulières
dès que cette classification sera fait
pour nos six départements et avec les
chambres d'agriculture
nous allons voir quel équilibre fer
entre le structurel et l'action procter
merci beaucoup monsieur bonneau
président de la région centre val de
loire
je vous retrouve ce soir à 19 heures
pour parler de sécurité alimentaire